validar el texto o no censurar
determinadas cláusulas el destino de la
ley de salud ahora está en manos del
consejo constitucional el elíseo se
muestra seguro
no estamos preocupados porque creemos
que el texto está equilibrado y ha
obtenido una opinión favorable del
consejo del estado que adopte el
proyecto de ley fue aprobado el 25 de
julio por la asamblea nacional y el
senado el ejecutivo espera que el texto
entre en vigor el 9 de agosto y aunque
si la vacunación obligatoria para
ciertos profesionales como los de la
salud ha logrado consenso la exigencia
del pase sanitario en la vida cotidiana
se divide tanto en el ámbito político
como en el social sin embargo muchos
franceses se oponen categóricamente a
mostrar un documento que acredite la
vacunación o muestra una prueba pcr
negativa cientos de miles de personas
salieron a las calles a protestar en las
últimas semanas
unipol y apoyamos la libre elección de
quienes quieran vacunarse lo hagan pero
que no impongan esto a las personas que
no quieren vacunarse vosotros
tendremos los vacunados los no vacunados
los que tienen el pase los que no tienen
el pase como será si mi padre quiere el
país en mis hijos no lo quieren no va a
funcionar
otro aspecto de la ley que también es
muy polémico es la cláusula que abre el
camino al despido de empleados que se
opongan al pase de salud en estructuras
abiertas al público será responsabilidad
del empleador garantizar el cumplimiento
de la legislación en ausencia de control
se expondría condenas